Hi, I'm Stan Muller, and this is the final
episode of Crash Course Intellectual Property.
Tackling such a huge subject in only seven
episodes has meant that we can't go into quite
as much detail as we'd like, but hopefully
we've given you a pretty good overview of
the basics of Intellectual Property. We spent
the last six episodes talking about copyright,
patent, and trademark laws as they currently
exist, but we keep running into a roadblock.
Intellectual Property law is slow to change, and we're living in a world that's changing pretty rapidly.
As we've noted again and again, our new digital
world has raised challenges for both consumers
and producers of IP. So today, we're going
to look at some of the problems that have
developed in recent years with Intellectual
Property. We're also going to talk about IP
as it applies to everyone's favorite internet
media hub, YouTube, and we're even going to
look into the future. I mean, we've got this
liquid-filled dye agitator containing a dye
with raised indicia on the facets thereof.
This thing tells the future, right?
It is certain!
[Theme Music]
So YouTube's kind of a big deal. It has over
a billion users watching hundreds of millions
of hours of video and generates billions and
billions of views. At the time we made this,
over 300 hours of video are uploaded to YouTube's
servers every minute, and in its ten year
history, YouTube has become the audiovisual wing in Google's attempt to build its archive of everything.
YouTube is truly vast, and it'll continue
to grow. It's arguably the most important
tool for speech and entertainment on the internet,
and we think it's probably the world's greatest and
most transformative teaching and learning tool. But as great as YouTube is, in a lot of ways, it's kind of a mess.
When over 300 hours of video are uploaded
every minute, 24 hours a day, some of it's
not going to be that great. While it's kind
of amazing and radically democratic that individual
vloggers and makers of cat videos and those
videos where they just open the toys and look
at them get to publish their videos side by
side with huge media companies, some creators
are concerned that their creative work is
cheapened and becomes just another piece of
content that gets lost amidst the junk, and
people aren't just uploading their own content.
Very often, people use this service to share
material they didn't create, so for pretty
much the entirety of YouTube's 10 year existence,
it's been getting sued.
In early 2007, Viacom opened the floodgates,
served over 100,000 take down notices, and
sued YouTube for $1 billion. Sports leagues,
music publishers, and other copyright owners
all filed class action suits based on the
same theory: YouTube and Google should be
held liable for the copyright infringements
committed by YouTube users. The issue here
was whether YouTube complied with Section
512 of The Copyright Act, which was added
in 1998 as part of the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act, or DMCA. The DMCA sets out
safe harbors to protect Internet Service Providers
or ISPs from unreasonable liability. Basically,
certain ISPs have to block or remove infringing content that it's aware of, or for which it receives a valid notice.
DMCA safe harbors protect Internet Service
Providers that comply with certain conditions
when they're engaged in one of four covered
activities. The first activity is when they're
acting as 'mere conduits', like the pipes
of the internet, for example, Comcast, Verizon
Fios, or Google Fiber. The second activity
is caching content, like Google does. The
third activity is hosting user-generated content,
like YouTube, and the fourth is acting as
an information location tool or search engine,
like Google or Bing.
The problem is, Congress came up with these
categories in 1998, which is like 80 years
ago in internet years. The DMCA doesn't fit
neatly with new categories of online services
including peer-to-peer sharing, torrents, and
cloud storage. The DMCA is due for an upgrade.
Let's take a closer look at the notice and takedown provision of the DMCA in the Thought Bubble.
So ISPs don't have to actively monitor for
infringement, but they do have to act if they
know about infringing content. ISPs know there's
infringing content on their system when they
receive a takedown notice or when they're
independently aware of it through either actual
knowledge or where it's obvious infringing activity
is going on. This is called 'red flag knowledge.'
Copyright owners and ISPs complain that the
notice and takedown system isn't working.
Rights holders complain that the system only
works for large corporate entities. Individuals
and small businesses can't afford to constantly
monitor for infringement and send thousands
of notices. Also the DMCA requires that content
be taken down only from the specific location
or URL identified in the notice. Once infringing
content, like Interstellar posted on YouTube,
is taken down, it just gets reposted in a
different location. Copyright owners call
it the whack-a-mole problem. ISPs complain
that the volume of takedown notices is overwhelming.
Google started keeping track of the take down
notices over the past several years. The number
has increased from about a 130,000 URLs per
week in 2011 to nearly 10 million per week
in 2015. Lots of these notices are sent using
automated systems, which sometimes leads to
erroneously removed content that doesn't and
can't take into account the fact that the
use might be fair. Also, there is some evidence
that the take down system is being abused
as a censorship tool, as in the case where
some candidates' political advertisements
have been targeted for removal during the
days leading up to a campaign, or as in the
case of video game companies flagging unfavorable
reviews as infringing content. Thanks Thought Bubble.
Now to get back to the Viacom v YouTube case,
the issue really centered around whether YouTube
had knowledge that infringing content
was being posted to the site,
and whether it induced users
to post such content.
In 2012, the second circuit court of appeals
held that in order for YouTube to lose its
safe harbor protections, it must have knowledge
or awareness of specific infringing activity.
So although YouTube was probably generally
aware that infringing content was being uploaded
because of the sheer volume of video being
posted and the fact they were being sued by
a lot of people who were loudly pointing out
that a lot of this content was infringing,
Viacom couldn't show that YouTube knew about
specific infringing content and ignored it.
After yet another appeal, Viacom and YouTube
settled the case in March of 2014. One big
reason for that settlement may have been YouTube's
2012 development of the content I.D. system.
With content I.D., YouTube allows certain
copyright owners to upload their content into
a database of protected material. YouTube
scans the uploaded content looking for a match
in the database. When there is a match, rights
holders can elect to either block or remove
the offending material, or monetize the video
by running ads against it.
Though content I.D. seems to have slowed all
the litigation, it's kind of really upset
the YouTube user community. Critics point
out that the automated system can censor fair
uses of protected content and sometimes unfairly
flag certain videos. Others claim that the
system doesn't go far enough, arguing that
YouTube gamed the DMCA in rapidly evolving
markets to turn a billion dollar lawsuit into
a lucrative business deal, and that YouTube
should be more proactive in ferreting out
infringing content.
In any case, it appears that content I.D.
is here to stay into the foreseeable future,
and there are probably several settlement
agreements that require its existence anyway.
For the time being, content I.D. will continue
to chip away at some YouTubers incomes, which
leads us to the issue of monetizing YouTube
videos. It's not an incredibly easy thing to do.
The difficulties inherent in generating income on YouTube become more complex when you talk about
freebooting, which is the unauthorized copying of online content and rehosting it on another website.
Unlike linking, sharing, or embedding the
file where the original creator is credited
and paid for any views that take place, the
freebooted file is actually downloaded and
reposted on another site where it generates
revenue. Our friend Destin at Smarter Every
Day made an excellent video about it that
you should watch.
Freebooting is kind of interesting; the companies
that are hosting these infringing videos have
something of a perverse incentive to slow
down the DMCA takedown process.
The longer the video is up of their site, the more views
and revenues it generates. While they're observing
the letter of the law and eventually taking
the stuff down, it seems a little fishy to me.
In any case, the compensation structure of
YouTube is often at odds with the incentive
structure of copyright law. Authors are granted
exclusive rights for a limited time so they
may financially benefit from their creation
either through sale of copies or licensing
access to the work. But this limited grant
of exclusive rights becomes less limited all
the time as copyright term is extended and
extended further into the future.
Speaking of the future, let's wrap things
up with a little futurism.
We're gonna look at a few problems with current
intellectual property law, and we're gonna
talk a bit about what the future might look
like. We painted a pretty rosy picture of
trademark law, and at its core it is a consumer
protection measure that really does function
pretty well. We all have to buy things, but
trademark law makes sure we can more easily
locate and buy the things we actually want and need, but owners sometimes overreach and abuse the system.
Trademarks are everywhere, and for better
or worse, they've taken on such a level of
importance to our day-to-day lives that it's
impossible to Photoshop out every soda bottle
or shirt logo in our videos. And by the way,
Photoshop is a registered trademark of Adobe
Systems Incorporated, not a generic term for
digital photo editing.
And even if our old friend T-Swizzie registers
phrases like "this sick beat" and other lines
from her songs, it's not that worrisome. Trademark
registrations don't give owners the right
to dictate how a phrase or mark is used. Trademarks
become problematic when owners try to use
them to restrain speech, like where a restaurant
threatens the author of a bad Yelp review
with trademark infringement.
So, patents are a little more of a mess. A
lot of recently issued patents are for inventions
that are unoriginal, vague, over-broad, or
so unclear that bad actors can easily use
them to threaten innovation. For example,
patents have been issued to basic technologies
like sending and receiving of streaming audio
and video over the internet, voice over IP
systems, and real-time multiplayer games.
To me, all of these seem like basic building
blocks for other products. These bad patents
seem to serve no function besides generating
license fees and curbing innovation. This
is really the case with software patents,
where inventions can be as abstract as a single
click to purchase a book or the idea of sorting
your Facebook friends into groups.
Patent trolls are non-practicing entities
that take advantage of these vague patents
by filing vague legal complaints. Even if
you've closely read the patent and you know
your stuff, it's kind of hard to figure out
how you've infringed the thing. There is patent
troll legislation currently pending in the
House that would require companies bringing
lawsuits to use greater detail in their documents,
and there's actually a good chance that this
patent troll legislation is going to pass
next year.
Okay, so we spend a lot of time on copyright
in this series because we encounter it so
often in our day-to-day lives. It's simply
inescapable, and judging from the comments
you posted, a lot of you really hate it. Law
professor Jane Ginsburg has an idea of how
copyright lost it, and got a bad name. She
attributes it to "Greed. Corporate greed and
consumer greed." Corporate owners trying to
increase earnings have lobbied for and gotten
more protective legislation that extends the term of
copyright and interferes with the development
of consumer-friendly copying technologies.
Consumers want to share content and get stuff
for free, and they feel that any law or enforcement
mechanism that gets in the way of what they
can do with their own equipment in their own
homes is illegitimate, and it's a threat to
the public interest. Copyright owners argue
that there are now so many creators that strong
exclusive rights are the best way to promote
the public interest.
So one thing I've noticed in the comments
is that you guys think copyright term is way
too long. Well, there's evidence to back this
belief up. Fewer than 11% of copyrights registered
between 1883 and 1964 were renewed at the
end of their 28-year term. Even though renewing
didn't cost very much. So back when stuff
could move to the public domain, copyright
owners let 89% of their works lapse, because
the works no longer had any economic value,
or the authors just didn't care anymore. In
our current system, the copyright term is
automatically life plus 70 years with no renewal
requirement. But a similar percentage of today's
copyright-protected works will likely be neglected
and forgotten about within a few decades,
or even a few years of their creation. The
only difference is that they're still protected
by copyright. This creates a huge body of
work that's under protection, but where the
author or owner often can't be found to grant
permission for use. There are called "orphan
works." Good-faith users that want to make
use of these works can't find the owner, can't
get permission, and therefore face the risk
that they'll be sued if the owner does eventually
step forward. The copyright office is advocating
for legislation that will limit liability
for good-faith users of orphan works who've
at least made some attempt to find the owner.
This legislation also might create a framework
for the private sector to develop rights clearance
mechanisms that will make it easier for creators
to use copyrighted work. It's possible that
Congress may consider introducing legislation
along these lines in the coming years,
but you know how Congress is.
There are also some really interesting private
initiatives that have tried to address the
super-long copyright term. Organizations like
Creative Commons and copyleft have attempted
to let creators choose how their work can
be used by others, and these movements have
gained some traction. It's hard not to just
argue that the term should be shorter, but
that's really hard to do. Changing US law
requires the revision and maybe renegotiation
of all these international treaties that further
entrench the life-plus-70 term, and the US
is signing more of these treaties all the time,
so unfortunately, the life-plus-70 term is here to stay.
So I may have given the impression here that
intellectual property law is a stinking cesspool
of greed and confusion, but I'm going to argue
that there is some value here. The basic notions--that
individual authors should be rewarded for
their creative efforts, that inventors should
profit from their inventions, and that manufacturers
of goods should be able to market their products
without fear that knockoffs will appear on
supermarket shelves--these are all good ideas.
Maybe you think they're not, but I believe
that we as a society can't neglect our creators
and innovators. We also can't allow outdated
laws to prevent technological innovation and
progress. The trick, as always, is striking
a balance, a combination of strong exclusive
rights for authors and inventors, and equally
strong exceptions and limitations that allow
for creators to build on work that came before.
Is this possible? "Reply hazy. Ask again later."
Well, there you have it. As usual on Crash
Course, there are no answers, only more questions.
Next week, we're going to start looking at
questions around the world economy with Crash
Course: Economics. Thanks for watching.
Crash Course: Intellectual Property is filmed
at the Chad and Stacey Emigholz Studio in
Indianapolis, Indiana; it's made by all of
these nice workers-for-hire. If you'd like
to keep Crash Course freely available for
everyone forever, you can support the series
at Patreon, a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love. Speaking
of Patreon, we'd like to thank all of our
supporters in general, and specifically thank
our Headmaster of Learning, Thomas Frank,
and our Vice Principals, Kathy and Tim Philip,
and Linnea Boyev. You can get awesome material
awards for your support, but I know that's
not why you're in this thing, you're in it
for the greatest reward of all, which is helping
people learn. Thanks for watching. We'll see
you next week.